hey this is a truly bizarre story
remember this guy milo yiannopoulos milo
yiannopoulos was this gay british
provocateur who got very involved in
american politics he was a darling of
the right and he would say horrible
things and then he had a sort of
uh it was it's not so much a falling out
he had i guess we'd call it a pr problem
because
he uh was in an interviewed in a show
and i want to be careful with the
language i use here
where he
sort of said it's kind of okay when
there are relationships between
he he wasn't saying prepubescent kids
but he was i i believe talking about
like
sort of like 12 and 13 year olds
and adult
men it was very very strange and he
quickly was dropped by the right wing
establishment they no longer he was no
longer useful to them and he's made a
couple of attempts at comebacks one of
the things he did is he became
heterosexual now i know that when i say
that you might be wondering well did he
really become heterosexual was he never
actually gay is it what what i i don't
know i'm just telling you he says he is
now heterosexual and um i i don't even
have an interest in commenting on
whether that's a real thing but he he
claims that he is now heterosexual and
this has allowed him to some degree
to at least attempt to re-en enter the
mainstream american political milieu
he now reportedly is marjorie taylor
green's unpaid intern this is just
bizarre it's it's wacky the washington
post reporting
milo yiannopoulos far-right provocateur
is a marjorie taylor green intern former
breitbart editor is summer intern for
marjorie taylor green he announced that
he had finally been persuaded out of
retirement
saying he was hired for an unpaid
internship with a friend
he attached a photo of a congressional
intern id badge on top of a louis
vuitton bag showing he's an intern in
marjory taylor green's office he her
office didn't explain what his duties
are
but she said so i have an intern that
was raped by a priest as a young teen
was gay has offended everyone at some
point turned his life back to jesus and
church and changed his life great story
great story
the statement was sent after the
washington post article published it
also suggested the media should
interview a colleague of hers about her
trans daughter
greene named the colleague using
transphobic language so it's a
completely bizarre story but it's not
only that milo appears to be an unpaid
intern of marjorie taylor green marjory
taylor green also now has a very strange
podcast
and he's off camera but he sort of seems
to be like a sidekick here this this is
one of the strangest stories i've seen
here is just 30 seconds of marjorie
taylor green's recent podcast episode i
believe this is from yesterday and you
hear milo off camera um
sort of her
her sidekick i guess listen to this tell
us more give us give us a give it tell
us about california well california has
advanced a bill to become a transgender
sanctuary it was introduced by democrat
senator scott weiner why are they always
called weiner why are they always called
weiner anthony weiner scott weiner they
all do all the wiener i don't think they
all go together
now that milo is heterosexual he can do
that type of thing i guess this is a new
form of comedy for milo now that he's
newly heterosexual they kind of some of
them are wanting to get rid of the
wieners i mean this is like like the
whole weenie chop thing can you imagine
being a mother wanting to do that to
your
child
i can't comprehend it i'm sorry i'm
making jokes but it's not funny yeah now
transphobia actually isn't new to milo
and there is a contingent
um there's a transphobic contingent of
the gay community this is just a thing
that exists it's not uh i'm not
personally attacking anyone there there
is
um you might have heard of trans
exclusionary radical feminism called
turf t-e-r-f there's also a contingent
of the gay community that is not big on
uh that that's not big on trans that
when milo was gay
and again i'm using
the language that he uses when milo used
to be gay he also uh was was transphobic
and in fact when i interviewed milo
years ago on the show
one of the things if i recall correctly
that we talked about and i don't know
who brought it up
were his views on uh feminism i'm sorry
we know his news on feminism where his
views on trans pho on transgender uh and
uh it exposed his transphobia so just
all very strange and i don't know what
the next step is like what is what's
interning for marjorie taylor green
where is that a jumping off point two
and i guess we can only wait and see if
it's just a summer internship by the way
milo's i think he's almost 40.
uh
i don't know
you know
it's all very strange but there it is
you now know everything that i know